[Music]
long continual learning is one of the
four interest topics for me
and it does relate to both artificial
intelligence and neuroscience as eliza
mentioned so in a sense it's kind of
their ultimate challenge seems to be
these days uh for artificial
intelligence systems to kind of bridge
the gap between the
artificial and natural intelligence
so i will briefly go over some
motivation and history of the field
which dates back to
1950s if not earlier as it started in
computational neuroscience
and inspirations from neuroscience kind
of fueled the research for a while
and most recently there was an explosion
of different approaches and settings
trying to solve their lifelong continual
learning problems especially in
deep neural networks i also touch upon
their recent
most challenging and exciting area of
continual reinforcement learning and i
will conclude this tutorial with some
recent open questions
and perhaps some controversial
discussions whether scaling of neural
net models can solve
their main issue of catastrophic
forgetting or maybe something more is
needed
so starting with motivation and history
well clearly you
all aware of
uh impressive results achieved by
artificial intelligence systems in the
past decade
from playing games and uh
beating human champions and chess gold
poker and stones of course to
generating uh
uh paintings that actually were
successfully sold at new york um art
auctions uh using guns for example and
definitely achieving or sometimes
beating human level accuracy in
detecting abnormalities in medical
imaging
and to the recent year uh kind of uh
really
amazing results in terms of generating
text which is pretty much
indistinguishable from human written
text by the
um
the gpga3 system and we're all kind of
waiting to see when gpt4 going to be
announced and what it's going to be able
to do but this idea of scaling
modern neural networks and training them
also on a humongous amount of data seem
to be bearing a fruit and we see
the results that we were never able to
see so far
but
what is recognized still as one of the
major limitations
is
the lack of breast or versatility in
this ai systems because they're still
somewhat narrow specialists
and as you all know we humans and
ideally uh artificial systems we want to
build should be able to be versatile
multitasking and be able to continually
kind of
acquire new skills and it doesn't still
have to be a system that is best at
everything and beating human champions
in all the games
but rather you would like to have a
system that may be good enough but at
extremely broad range of tasks just like
we humans are
well how do we get there how do we
achieve this
versatility so the typical past there is
through lifelong or
continual learning essentially constant
expansion and development of your
abilities and acquiring increasingly
more complex behaviors building upon
what you learned in the past and
as i will be talking soon are also
avoiding issue called catastrophic
forgetting
so
examples of practical applications where
artificial systems will need such
versatility and ability to learn
continually range from classical
continual learning challenge of robotics
where the robot
has to learn to do new tasks in new
environments and um keep uh kind of
learning that without
uh completely forgetting what the
chlorine they go
to
obviously systems that control
autonomous vehicles
and change environment from country road
to the city
um to highway
obviously systems that
maintain conversations with people
conversational agents of different kind
they should be very flexible because the
situations uh change in which they
supposed to be helping the person and
also the person may be changing and
even with one person there will be a lot
of adaptations required
for just that specific person leave a
long adaptation of conversational agents
across different users
and here's
one of my favorite movies movie her
where the conversational agent turned
out to be extremely flexible and
continually learning
and examples go on and on uh there are
many of course important medical
applications
such as medical imaging where it's
really important to have systems that
can
learn on
data from one hospital for example and
generalize to data from different
hospital learn continually from patient
to patient and from disorder to disorder
because unfortunately most of the time
in practice right now you have to
retrain those systems from scratch on
the new data sets but if you believe
that there is something common and
variant
about the disorder you really would like
to exploit all the data sets that you
will be encountering during your
lifetime of the system and incorporate
that information in the flexible way
so what is one of the key problems
identified with continual learning and
this as i said dates uh back to the
previous century of course uh way before
modern
large-scale deep neural networks the
problem was uh encountered multiple
times
in computational neuroscience uh and um
one most notable paper was a paper from
1989 by my claustron where they
demonstrated that when they train
a neural network using propagation just
the classical
standard neural net on the problem of
learning how to do
one sums one's addition facts like
one plus one two plus one three plus one
and so on the system can learn it well
but the moment they switch to the two
addition facts it starts forgetting
really quickly what it learned before to
the point that in
a few trials performance drops to like
20 from 100 and a few more trials and
system completely catastrophically
forgets what it learned before
so this phenomenon
actually is a part of more general
challenge
in both computational neuroscience
trying to understand how our brains
adapt to new situations how plasticity
happens without losing stability or
memory and how do we implement that
potentially in artificial neural
networks so catastrophic uh interference
or catastrophic forgetting is just uh
one part of this general issue because
you need both
plasticity to change quickly when the
environment changes but you also need
stability so you don't forget what you
learned before
and there is a long history of
continual learning and this chart is
highly
sketchy and complete as i apologize in
advance but i try to put together at
least
partially
some
points in the history when terminology
was introduced a particular important
findings were discovered and it all can
be even dated back to the sensitivity
stability trade-off
described by hub in 1949 to the
stability plasticity dilemmas that i
mentioned on the previous slide and then
various methods that were trying to
avoid catastrophic forgetting mainly
developed during 90s in
computational neuroscience literature
and then most recently
uh they really were picked up on uh in
the deep learning community uh because
once we managed to achieve those
impressive results with deep neural nets
in specific tasks the next question was
exactly so now how do we learn this
ability
uh to perform it all and be versatile
just like we humans do it
so recent
recent five years i would say witnessed
exponential growth in the number of
papers in the continual lifelong
learning
area
talking about neuroscience uh there are
of course multiple inspirations that
were used over the past few decades but
the most notable ones i would say were
related to
three concepts that i will describe in
the following three slides
so um
basically
plasticity is most of the time are meant
to be synoptic so when we talk about
plasticity of neural net we meant
adaptation of synaptic weights
and the interesting thing is that some
recent experiments also kind of support
uh that earlier hypothesis that
when we learn a new task
and in this case it was an experiment um
basically using
but basically looking at the strings of
the synapses looking at their size of
our dendritic spines corresponding to
those when we learn a new task uh some
of them get enlarged so they correspond
to the synapses that are uh kind of
taking care of solving the task roughly
speaking
the interesting thing is that those
changes do persist over like long time
like months and uh we do not forget the
task we learned but if you actually
directly intervene and use some uh
approaches from synaptic optogenetics
you kind of uh revert those changes
then the task will be forgotten so it's
really telling you that
certain
synapses
will be responsible for representing and
solving particular tasks and therefore
you may want to do something like that
when you train your um
deep neural net you want to
dedicate certain certain weights certain
connections to particular tasks and make
sure that you protect them from being
washed out by more recent training and
this idea gave rise to multiple
approaches in the past including um a
relatively recent elastic weight
consolidation method that um
became quite popular and kind of gave
rise to many
uh recent approaches
um i'll talk briefly about that in a few
minutes
uh but i also want to mention another um
kind of quite famous theories that gave
rise to
a different
computational approaches and this is so
called complementary learning systems
uh the areas so it also dates back to
90s to 1995 if not earlier and the idea
is that we have um kind of
at least two parts of the memory system
we have the fast learning hippocampus
that essentially learns episodic
information and then later on it is
consolidated in neocortex usually during
sleep or arrest
into more structured knowledge
that can be used to generalize to
kind of new situations and this inspired
whole bunch of approaches
in the recent continual learning
literature uh that are based on the
replay or rehearsal uh by analogy with
how the information from hippocampus is
being consolidated during sleep
and stored in near cortex by means of
replaying the activations in hippocampus
that were associated with particular uh
episodes
so essentially this replay rehearsal
approaches are quite
often used in modern
modern methods for continual learning
and can be also combined with various
other approaches
i will give some taxonomy of those
so finally um another kind of notable
uh third inspiration from neuroscience
is the one that led i guess to the
modern um so-called architectural
methods this uh inspiration essentially
tells you that sometimes synaptic
plasticity may not be enough and
sometimes if the environment changes
drastically and significantly it might
be useful to expand the architecture of
your network by analogy with so-called
neurogenesis or which even happens in
adult mammals and humans
particularly adult neurogenesis means
growth and incorporation of new neurons
in specific areas of the brain
particularly hippocampus
uh it's pretty much the only area where
it happens in humans and and other
mammals it also may happen in a factory
bulb but the bottom line is that when
there are changes in the environment are
sufficiently
significant it may pay off to expand
your architecture of your network and
locally speaking that's kind of
inspiration to a third branch of
modern
computational continual learning methods
i will be talking about the first one as
i mentioned based on the synaptic
plasticity and freezing weights that are
responsible for tasks led to various
regularization approaches the second
based on the
separation between slow and fast
learning hippocampus and
neocortex
led to replay and then your genetic
approach has led to architecture based
methods in continual learning
okay so let us now go to the
brief overview of the modern supervised
continue learning because just like with
machine learning in general the
supervised part is most developed these
days although there is lots of recent
research uh in uh unsupervised continual
learning and as i will mention in the
most challenging uh domain
out of those in continual reinforcement
learning
so here is uh essentially an overview of
the continual learning setting
in supervised
problems
and it's compared to the standard
supervised learning in the standard one
as you know
you take
inputs x and their labels y
in the given data set you assume that
there is one
distribution from which the data will be
coming during training and tests you
learn the model and during the test time
you will be tested on samples from the
same distribution
however in continual learning
you have a stream
of potentially different data
distributions and different tasks
each associated with its own
set of samples
so you have those inputs and outputs x
and y's coming from distribution one so
then switching to distribution two and
potentially the infinite stream of
different
data
distributions your learner acts in
online versus offline manner
and it has to essentially
learn all those tasks because each time
it may be tested on all the previous
tasks seen so far that's why you would
like the method to adapt to new data
sets and still be able to remember how
to solve the previous ones
well clearly continual learning relates
to many
sub areas of modern machine learning
that have in common the same component
of having multiple data distributions
and trying to somehow
come up with a model that can
make use of all those data
and also be able to handle at least some
new distributions
like um
multitask learning is perhaps the most
classical baseline kind of comparison
when you given set of data distributions
but simultaneously
so learning is offline unlike continual
learning
and
essentially you can shuffle the data
which is not an option in continual
online learning
and
you can essentially
uh use one model you're trying to trade
model with shared set of parameters that
will work well on all these um different
tasks simultaneously during the testing
you will be given samples uh again
coming from distributions of those tasks
but nothing
out of distribution
so there is no continual model
adaptation here it's offline approach
okay so
so transfer learning is another kind of
closely related but simpler setting
where you typically have source task and
target task up to data distributions and
you try to transfer knowledge um from
the model learned on the first task to
perform better on the second task but
you don't really care about
keeping the performance on the first
task
uh again there is no continuous
adaptation here after you learn the
target task
there is no online infinite stream of
changing environments
and as i mentioned the source task
performance doesn't matter anymore once
you transfer your kind of knowledge to
that new one
the main adaptation is also closely
related of course so it's kind of
a particular case of transfer learning
where the source and target tasks are
the same but the input domains are
different again
same
uh same comparison with continual
learning this is
unidirectional you do not accumulate
knowledge in the infinite stream and you
do not really care about performance on
the previous
data sets after you transfer knowledge
to the new one
finally are there kind of um
most popular recently and kind of rich
area of this type of multi-task and
multi-environment learning is meta
learning
and there are many methods developed
recently to solve this type of problems
but the second is
again offline you assume that there is a
certain distribution
of
distributions of the tasks
you draw a set of different data sets
from this distribution
each data set belongs to its own
data distribution
and you must train single model so that
during the test time
when it will be presented with yet
another new data distribution
not something you've seen in the train
time uh it will be able to do well on it
it will be allowed to adopt in a few
short
kind of manner so you're really trying
to learn um
a model that can be easily adapted to a
large variety of different new data sets
of course with certain assumptions of
how they relate to the old data sets on
which you train
again the problem here
as compared to continual learning is
that
we're learning offline we have access to
all these different data sets
simultaneously
and
once we
switch to the test mode we do not
usually care about how well we will
perform on the previous datasets so
continue learning seem to be the most
challenging setting out of all of those
because it combines the temporal
sequential nature of learning with the
desire to transfer knowledge not only to
the
future but also take care of not
forgetting the past
and by the way a notable
important example uh related to all the
settings is so called out of
distribution generalization and you
perhaps can view it as
seeking specific setting of meta
learning uh as zero-shot meta learning
and the classical example comes from the
invariant risk minimization paper by
jose
and his colleagues at facebook uh which
actually inspired the whole area of
recent
robust predict uh prediction papers
which i unfortunately don't have time to
cover here but i really encourage you to
take a look at the related work and the
classical example is
that
most of the
modern deep network systems
will break if they will be asked to
perform on the data that have
distribution sufficiently different from
the one they were trained on for example
if they were trained to classify animals
and they only seen examples of cows on
green pastures
and then during tests they will suddenly
see cows on the beach
most of the times those system
performance will really go down quite a
bit
and the reason is there is also another
interesting paper kind of uh summarizing
this tendency of deep nets
uh to rely on so-called shortcut
features or spuriously correlated
features which do not have
really anything to do with the concept
of animal here but they're easier to
detect and rely on such as a green
background
and the goal of
recent
approaches to more kind of robust out of
distribution generalization
including that famous paper by
archeovsky is to
figure out how to
regularize how to constrain your model
and the process of learning it so that
you will be able to
extract
those invariant features for example of
animal over cow while ignoring the
spurious shortcut features such as color
of the background and there are
different approaches to that as i said
it's extremely interesting um and
rapidly growing area i encourage you to
look into but very briefly the idea say
of irm is that
you will be aiming
at learning a mapping from the input
from say pixel space into representation
space
so that essentially will be able to
learn invariant or robust set of
features there so that you can be
simultaneously optimal
with this set of features in terms of
predicting uh the type of animal
across
a variety of different data sets or
so-called environments
and that's kind of where the
out-of-distribution uh sitting connects
with metal learning at the train time
you will be given a set of environments
and your job is to find features that
are robust or invariant
across all the environments with respect
to predicting the plus label
okay
so
um back to continuous learning setting
as i mentioned their main challenge that
distinguishes this setting from all the
previous ones that i mentioned is it
happens online
and it happens sequentially and unlike
out of distribution or meta-learning
type of settings uh you do not
have access to all the previous tasks
when you are switching to a new one
so what kind of particular citations can
happen here so cml has
access input vector wires label and you
have the task or context
uh such as i don't know classifying
animals and then classifying um
i know
buildings
to classifying plants and so on so forth
uh what can happen here you may or may
not be told what task you're doing now
so the t may be observed or not observed
and it also can be observed both during
training and test time
or not depending on which of this
condition
is satisfied you will have several
different type of settings for continual
learning and briefly speaking if you
observe the task
id if you have oracle telling you when
task changes during training it's the
simplest case called task incremental
continual learning while if that's not
the case
and when the new tasks arrive uh you
will kind of
potentially even have new classes it
will be called class incremental
continual learning and there is also
related um
setting called the main incremental
continuous learning
and when you just do not know any
boundary between those tasks it's the
most challenging task agnostic setting
anyway i'm probably not gonna have much
time to go into the details and just
give you the high level idea but as i
said task incremental is the simplest
setting when model is always aware of
which task it's solving for example it's
told that now you will be classifying
animals now you're crucifying buildings
and in this situation it's simple to
have so-called multi-head architecture
and try to learn common representation
but for each specific task you will have
its own predictor
there are some the main assumption here
is just that the set of
labels that you will be predicting in
each task
might change
across time
and that's a schematic representation of
what i was just saying during training
you have a clear task boundaries
and during tests you also are told what
to classify now whether it's like animal
tasks or the building tests
and
multi-head architecture is
easy way to handle this problem
essentially so what is in common is the
rest of the network which learns say
good representation across all these
different tasks
the next more challenging setting is
when
you are not given the task identity
during tests
and
that picture
kind of summarizes what's going on
during training you know that you are
classifying
um
say images in particular
tasks
say animals and then buildings
and so on and so forth
while during tests you are not told
where that
image the test image comes from a
particular task you need to figure out
which task it came from and um
as well classified properly
and finally there is a related domain
incremental continual learning
uh which only differs from the previous
previous one with one specific
assumption
and that assumption is that the
distribution
and distribution over class labels does
not change just to give you example of
what it means in a specific
um
data set
imagine you are um given the task of
learning a sequence of split amines
tasks so first you have to learn to
classify
zero from one
then two from three and so on so forth
so that's why it's called splitum nice
because it's splitted into
several separate tasks
and here is what happens in each of the
three scenarios that i mentioned
so with incremental task learning
you will be given the task you will be
told that you're solving task one or
task three or task five both during
training and during tests and your only
question is to figure out uh to answer
correctly the question whether the image
belongs to the first class or the second
is it zero one or eight or nine but you
know the identity of task
in incremental the main learning
task is not known
but you just
want to know whether
your class label belongs to the first or
second class
you need to figure that in incremental
class learning you also need to figure
not just whether it's first or second
level but which digit it is so you also
need to figure out which task that
sample came from so that's kind of most
challenging uh task incremental setting
you will have to keep learning um all
those objects of different classes and
the number of pluses keeps increasing
and finally as i mentioned even more
challenging setting is when the identity
of the task is not given to you
neither during
tests
nor during training and essentially you
may need to be able to detect
um kind of non-stationarity detect the
change
between the tasks in your data
there are
multiple other kind of frameworks that
were and the settings that uh kind of
were developed recently including
um meta continual learning and continual
meta learning kind of schematically
represented here so on and so forth and
in general that field of continual
learning seemed to be
having the explosion of specific
problem settings and that's kind of one
of the
one of the issues how to
uh kind of organize them in some
unifying framework so you essentially i
can compare methods uh like you can
compare apples to oranges so you know
like what exactly your setting assumes
about that
changes in the environment changes in
the tasks what information is available
to your learner and what the evaluation
criteria are
so there is lots of work in this area
one particular paper um you could take a
look at um
from last year in eurips was trying to
unify uh these previous settings
including meta continual and continual
meta in one framework
uh and essentially extend the meta
learning um
in metal learning algorithm the famous
mammal model agnostic metal learning to
the continual setting with quite a
successful results showing that in that
kind of a generic setting uh using this
approach uh indeed indeed pays off and
beats the state award
again i'm
unable to go into all the details and
encourage you to look at this
paper and um
one step back are just to see what
exactly the challenge is so
we can go to the methods and see how
different classes or types of approaches
try to attack that challenge so
essentially what you're trying to do in
this online non-stationary continual
learning
as i mentioned you have sequence of data
distributions from which the samples
were drawn
ideally if you had all this data
available to you or you just kept
storing the infinite stream of data
your natural objective would be your
empirical risk minimization across all
these tasks you would
sum the expected risk for each task
across all of them unfortunately you do
not have access to previous tasks either
due to a real-time nature of the problem
like in robot learning or simply due to
the issue of
your inability to maybe just store
infinite amounts of data if you
uh if your intention is to build a
system that can learn um life long uh
infinitely plus sometimes considerations
are
basically cost efficiency if you running
continue learning agents on edge devices
on your phone or on the
robot with some limited memory on it
it's simply uh infeasible to keep all
the data accumulated during the robot
lifetime and
constant communication with some
centralized server may be also expensive
or not always possible
so what happens
uh in this situation as i mentioned the
catastrophic forgetting problem in
general
that was observed in computational
neuroscience literature uh keeps popping
up here and the classical example from
the ewc paper was uh
showed that standard stochastic gradient
descent
applied to a sequence of tasks will
train
and do well on the first task but the
moment it starts adapting to second task
information about the previous task is
being washed out performance degrades
the new task is shown performance keeps
degrading further and further therefore
you need to do something
some form of memory to avoid uh kind of
this catastrophic forgetting issue of a
naive standard neural net learning with
stochastic gradient
and essentially this is as i mentioned
more general problem of stability versus
specificity
which in a sense can be
viewed as a problem of knowledge
transfer to the future
to perform hopefully better after
learning from several tasks and lack of
interference interference or also kind
of positive transfer to the past at
least not forgetting how to do well on
previous data and perhaps even improve
your performance on those data
so that's the ultimate goal
one common way of measuring transfer and
appearance in various approaches i'll
mention some of them briefly
is to simply look at the
dot product of gradients
at the samples from new tasks and the
previous tasks and essentially you can
think about that as
uh if
my current step
in terms of updating base on my new
samples
um goes in the opposite direction
for them over the direction of the
gradient uh from the previous task i'm
kind of forgetting i'm kind of making
model perform worse on my previous
samples so ideally i would like those
gradients to be aligned and that would
facilitate transfer while um gradients
looking into opposite directions uh most
likely gonna lead to interference
between the tasks and um that may lead
to catastrophic forgetting
just to kind of summarize possible
scenarios of what can happen with
transfer to the future and transfer for
not forgetting to the past
uh there are roughly these five
situations which are nicely described in
the recent survey
uh from last year on continual learning
uh reference below
and there are some situations that are
desirable and others that you would like
to avoid
so
two bad situations are
forgetting as we already mentioned when
performance on the earlier tasks keeps
degrading
but another also bad situation is when
you're too stable and you lack
plasticity
so you learn the first task and perform
well on that but you're unable to learn
anything new
on the contrary good situations would be
when either you have boost stability
plasticity and you keep performing as
well as you did on previous tasks
while learning new tests
possibly learning previous tasks helps
you to actually improve
uh learning of the new task it's even
positive uh forward transfer and the
ideal situation is not just positive
forward but also positive backward
transfer when learning new tasks
helps you to even perform better on the
previous one
so that's what can happen
what really happens in practice
mainly depends on both
data properties
and
method properties and right now um i
just want to say that the field of
continual learning is
quite empirical there is a proliferation
of different approaches
and there is a clear lack of
theoretical understanding of what works
when and where
so just to give you some high level
overview
i want to mention
as i kind of alluded to it before
talking about your scientific uh
inspirations replay methods as you
remember this so-called memory based
replay methods uh assume that you will
replay or somehow keep some
representative samples of previous tasks
and that will help you to
not completely forget the information
about the previous tasks while adapting
to new ones
so another approach is not to keep
any kind of uh
samples uh in memory but really try to
operate on the weights that you learn
and that's the second category of
so-called regularization based methods
as i mentioned before in neuroscience
inspirations
they relate to this idea that when we
learn certain tasks particular weights
particular synapses
are assigned to those tasks and we may
want to protect those weights from
future changes when learning new tasks
so there is a whole class of approaches
based on this idea and finally
again very roughly
kind of along the lines of neurogenetic
ideas from neuroscience there are so
called architecture based
or parameter resolution methods where
you are allowed to expand your
architecture if needed to accommodate uh
then new tasks and the need to represent
more information
again we don't have much time remaining
and i will only very very briefly
uh kind of give you the taxonomy
of those methods with a few examples you
are very welcome to
read this
survey that i'm citing here by
the launch at all and continue learning
at the end of the
uh of this lecture i will also give you
a list of other recent tutorials
as i mentioned the number of methods
proposed recently is really large and
keeps growing very rapidly
so replay methods have several
subtypes uh either they're kind of based
on this rehearsal so pseudo rehearsals
or not storing
their exact samples from the past but
rather generating them from some
generative models also constrained
methods a few examples and i apologize
for really going extremely quickly
gradient episodic memory paper uh very
nice one based on the
constraint that you want the gradients
of old
and new kind of samples
to at least not contradict each other
therefore the constraint at the bottom
that product of the gradient should be
non-negative
um
at that point they generated
state-of-the-art results
later on um meta experience replay
approach in the same category you use
replay previous samples
uh to keep information from
representative information from previous
tasks you use the idea of gradient
alignment as well but here you make it
part of your objective rather than just
constrained
and you actually beat the previous
method and some others and again this is
not the most recent method there are
even better ones right now
so on and so forth generative replay
where instead of
storing samples of previous tasks you
rather build generative models which can
generate representative samples and add
those to a current data set
um
so basically that's so-called
pseudorehearsal or generative replay
type of methods and there are many
approaches along this line again i
highly recommend this recent paper by
van de ven
um on this type of approaches
there is second class roughly speaking
besides replay regularization based
methods
and um there are many of them again
you're welcome to look at the
uh survey
listed at the bottom of the page
classical examples is a famous elastic
weight consolidation paper
from 2017 which by now is of course
outperformed by many recent approaches
but it's a classical benchmark for
various comparisons
and the idea there was precisely
motivated by the
synoptic consolidation
inspiration from neuroscience that you
try to
you try to protect the weights that are
most important for learning previous
tasks from
changes imposed while you're adapting to
new tasks
which way you do it precisely through
regularization and details you can see
in the paper there is a whole bunch of
approaches along the same lines which
different terms of what regularizer you
use
but the idea of protecting task specific
weights is
common and again the classical picture
that is often used to demonstrate how to
avoid catastrophic forgetting for
getting is this one
finally the
so-called parameter isolation or
architectural approaches methods uh also
have several subclasses some
fix network architecture but try to pack
the weights for different tasks into
different parts of the network while
others actually expand the architecture
and the list of methods here is quite
long from the relatively simplistic
pacnet paper where the network is fixed
and you kind of try to allocate sparse
subsets of weights to different tasks
and then you keep um kind of learning
the remaining ones
uh for the new tasks
and uh essentially yes this approach uh
has some advantages over just fixed
networks um
and even uh the second type of work with
expanding architectures progressive
networks but uh they kind of
only add fixed number of neurons while
and this method of dynamic expandable
networks they were really being smart
about how many new neurons to add so on
and so forth there are many interesting
papers along those lines
uh there are very different style of
approaches still falling into category
of architectural for example um i really
like this neural dilution process
paper
uh
essentially they use their kind of
patient approach to building sub
networks or experts and only introducing
a new one when the data cannot be
explained well by the previous ones and
they show how to apply it and continue
learning setting
yet another approach directly motivated
by neurogenesis ideas i mentioned was
our paper a while ago
on essentially how to
how to expand and compress if needed uh
hidden layers so that you will adapt to
changing sequence of tasks but at the
same time you avoid extending the model
infinitely
and analogy with human neurogenesis is
that we have the birth of new neurons in
hippocampus but we also have deaths of
neurons that are not being used
and
essentially if the complexity of
environment
is relatively low
then not much neurogenesis or new
neurons is remaining essentially it's
kind of use it or lose it
type of a situation and indeed if you
show uh sufficiently rich and changing
set of environments to your model or an
empirical neuroscientific papers to your
animal like i put rat into
a rich and changing environment
more neurogenesis happens and also
performance on the
kind of continual learning type of test
is better so that's what we also
observed with our
kind of simple autoencoder model uh
which
in the neurogenetic setting
was ending up with models that were
always adapting better to new data and
not forgetting all data
while same size
but fixed size models were not as
flexible as we kind of found empirically
essentially supporting their empirical
observations from those
neuroscience papers and neurogenesis
anyway so just kind of to conclude this
whole idea of expanding
networks and growing architecture with
like some high level view what the role
of continued learning could be as you
might have heard um there is lots of um
discussions and papers along the lines
of
compositionality and recombination of
certain
uh basic uh independent components or
mechanisms in order to improve
uh models generalization to
say out of distribution type of data and
so on so the idea here could be that
exposing your model to
challenging
diverse and complex environments in
continued learning setting can be a
method for producing
this expanding set of the core
mechanisms that can be recombined
to solve
any problem that will come your way in
the future if you assume that all those
data sets problems or tasks
from the world
that continual learning agents should
live in if they allow for some finite
basis
because each problem
and supervised learning can be seen as a
function approximation problem if this
set of functions can be well
approximated in some finite basis by
certain recombination of these basis
functions then you have a hope of
learning finite network that can deal
with infinite set of tasks as long as
they're coming from the world with the
properties that they just mentioned
somewhat similar to how we developed a
finite size brain
with certain components responsible for
different
somewhat orthogonal tasks
motor visual auditory and recombination
of those allows us to
successfully solve many different
problems
i know i'm running a little bit out of
time but i just wanted to very briefly
mention
this new
and
most challenging and exciting field of
continual reinforcement learning
which is even kind of as i said more
challenging than supervised learning
because you
have a agent actively affecting the
environment in which this agent acts
uh without too much detail i would refer
you to our recent survey on um
continuous
um essentially it goes over different
sources of non-stationarity and
different types of them whether it
depends on environment only or
environment is also affected by actions
of
agent and that poses non-stationarity or
combinations of that it gives taxonomy
of existing approaches to continue
reinforcement learning
and it discusses
desirable properties of benchmarks
because
it seemed to be one of the key uh
important
components
of making continual learning continual
reinforcement learning successful how to
decide how to design sufficiently
challenging
uh benchmarks
also
um in some controlled ways that you can
increase their complexity and you
control that and so on and so forth it
also discusses different metrics way
beyond just a cumulative reward
that you would like your agent to
optimize
and
that's kind of interesting uh food for
thought as well when you develop new
methods
so on and so forth it discusses open
problems
uh in particular this area
and uh inspirations from neuroscience
that you could borrow
just uh building upon the previous
successive successes of neural inspired
approaches and continue learning
and the final point that i just wanted
to make well two final points
uh very briefly this is kind of just um
advertisement of the recently developed
uh
unifying framework a library for
different
settings
methods and kind of continual learning
problems including supervised
and reinforcement learning called square
yeah if you're interested i can always
provide you a link uh to github it's
open source and you're welcome to use it
and build on top of that it was
developed by students at mila
fabrice normanden and massimo and a
large group of people working with them
during the past year
and finally an open question there is
lots of discussions recently about the
role of scaling
in
neural networks
especially motivated by recent successes
of gpt3
and this one of the recent talks along
those lines about explaining neural
scaling laws
by the way for those of you who are not
yet familiar with this area the scaling
laws are empirical kind of observations
about how
various neural net architectures behave
on different type of tasks
with increasing data set
size model size and compute and bottom
line empirically it has been found in
the past year that most of the time they
follow power laws but the question is
what properties of algorithms and models
make those power laws
converge faster to smaller error which
ones are better
there is a hypothesis
being discussed whether scaling neural
net models can maybe solve continual
learning and just get rid of
catastrophic forgetting problem
completely with some promising results
but in
very
limited setting with a few tasks well as
you expect
larger models should have more capacity
and yes eventually they can incorporate
both tasks or even like 10 tasks like
mentioned in the talk
but the question is um
is there a limit to that and it seems
that besides scaling your model and the
data you train on you should probably
consider another dimension which can be
complexity of continual learning
environment in a sense of
how diverse the tasks are and if you
push that complexity of environment
further
i bet that there must be some trade-off
uh between that complexity and the
capacity of your model and size of your
model um
and would be interesting to know what
the tradeoff is
so you may need to scale model beyond a
certain level to capture certain
complexity of the environment
and totally uh speculative slide is that
perhaps
to truly capture continual learning um
the way humans do it we may need to even
go beyond the
modern artificial neural network
kind of designs and not just to allow
for growing neural networks standard way
but maybe new types of neural networks
maybe richer
networks allowing um for
extra
capacity for example representing time
perhaps or not that's an open question
so um i will conclude here
by listing
the ultimate
wish list of properties of continued
learning systems and i also refer you to
various recent surveys as i mentioned
on the topic
and i'm pretty sure more surveys being
written as we speak
and
thank you very much
for more details you can also take a
look at our recent html tutorial on the
same subject thank you amazing amazing
irena thank you so much for just this
just extensive and thorough survey of
continual learning i learned so much i'm
a neuroscientist by training and so i
was really
inspired uh by what you shared
how the insights from neuroscience are
being applied now to to this field and
the the state of the art and the open
questions i think this is a really
really exciting area of research we have
a ton of questions that have come in i
do remind our participants to upvote
rather than enter your own questions
irena will be able to answer a few of
them
offline so we'll share these with her
after the lecture and we'll even try to
stay
uh maybe for a total of five minutes for
the q a right now irina and so let's try
to do um some of the most popular
questions right off the bat
um and so the first uh question is if to
ask you to share with us a few examples
of unsupervised continual learning
well uh one example is a curl paper
a few years ago basically on
unsupervised engineering learning but
you can think about
uh in a sense that it's nothing um
i mean there's several references like i
will be happy to provide the list of
papers but in a sense uh
if you think about trying to
learn as a distribution of the data
that incorporates multiple different sub
distributions roughly speaking there is
nothing
too specific to the
supervised setting i mean you can think
about trying to capture
variety of data distributions in one
model and those data distributions will
be corresponding to unsupervised setting
where you would like to
model your samples and be able to
reconstruct them accurately yeah so in a
sense it's not surprising that there is
a field it's just a bit less
uh explored just because of popularity
of supervised learning but yeah also i'd
be happy to provide more um
uh more references uh the paper paper
called curl is like one example sure
yeah and we can just append those to
your your q a document and the icml
tutorial by the way the second part of
it uh given by me and with sen solomon
so he talked a bit more on unsupervised
continued learning exactly so if you
follow that link and go to the part two
you'll find more there
okay great that's a really helpful
resource okay the next question is uh in
a supervised setting how can the
imbalance in the number of data samples
per task impact the learning
oh i mean imbalance um
i mean class imbalance is always a
potential issue
so i i think i mean there is
no specific continual learning related
consideration that
kind of really
just just like with
usual supervised learning if you have
high class imbalance
uh you might
you might not be able to represent
properly as a second class so you will
need to do something about that
and um
yeah so i don't think that continual
learning adds any extra complexity so
any method that you would use to handle
class imbalance perhaps can be
incorporated in the continual learning
study
great okay that's great advice
uh next question uh how much does the
curriculum matter in a continual
learning setup to design a curriculum
how would we go about creating a
suitable set of scaffolds to learn
effectively
yeah this is a great question and yes it
matters a lot
and indeed uh i mean
especially with
yeah with sufficiently
different distributions of data in
different tasks
again there are situations when gradual
kind of
increase of complexity by
slowly changing the task distribution
may be better for model learn instead of
the drastic change but it also depends
on your approach
and
say this drastic changes certain methods
uh such as maybe architectural that
allow for expanding the
architecture who are good at detecting
that the change is drastic and
introducing
and constructing a new part of the model
those might work better if
actually you design the curriculum to be
more challenging and the changes are
more abrupt but in general yes it's
highly relevant question it's often
empirical the answers are frequently
empirical you need to investigate
for which type of methods and models
what type of curricula by the best
but in general in general the rule of
thumb is that curriculum should be
sufficiently challenging
if you would like to develop a model
that is more versatile and
definitely if you use some very basic
benchmarks such as rotated or permutated
this is not enough of curriculum to
learn truly uh generalizing models it
has to be has to be more complex than
that it's great okay it's the last
question that we have time for to answer
live
uh how does continual learning relate to
the online learning literature
yeah i mean it relates directly so you
essentially can think about continual
learning as online
non-stationary learning
it is online learning but the classical
online learning typically assumes that
the data stream comes from the same
distribution while continual learning
assumes that there will be change points
whether abrupt or some kind of drifts
and that's a main difference between
classical online learning and
non-stationary or continual online
learning right it's a lot more dynamic
in the continual learning context right
great okay so i'm afraid that's all we
have time for but irina what a wonderful
lecture thank you so much for such a
deep dive such a thorough examination of
the topic we really enjoyed it thank you
[Music]
you